paso firme en la defensa de las mujeres
del mundo tras la preocupación que se
mantiene por el caso PenSuite la W
organismo que rige el tenis profesional
femenino anuncio la cancelación de todos
sus torneos en China una decisión que
había sido advertida en el pasado por su
presidente asumiendo las consecuencias
que ello generaría no veo cómo puedo
pedirle a nuestros atletas que compiten
allí cuando a Pencho ahí no se le
permite comunicarse libremente y
aparentemente ha sido presionada para
contradecir su acusación de agresión
sexual
es una publicación el pasado 2 de
noviembre la red social china Weibo en
la que acusó a un viceprimer ministro
chino de abuso sexual tras darse a
conocer el suceso la publicación fue
borrada de Internet y transcurrieron
varias semanas sin saber sobre su
paradero que generaron preocupación en
el mundo deportivo y organismos como la
ONU ONG como Amnistía Internacional y
gobiernos como el de Estados Unidos la
medida de la W género diversas
reacciones de respaldo aplaudo a Steve
Simón y al lado Bleu está por adoptar
una postura firme en la defensa de los
derechos humanos en China y en todo el
mundo la doble está en el lado correcto
de la historia al apoyar a nuestras
jugadoras gracias a la doble por tener
el valor de enfrentarse al Partido
Comunista Chino y suspender todos los
torneos encina desde la desaparición de
la estrella del tenis PenSuite hasta
obligar a los uigures musulmanes a
trabajar como esclavos China comunista
no respeta la humanidad en 2019 China
albergo ocho eventos del circuito
femenino de tenis la decisión se
presenta justo cuando China se alista
para recibir los Juegos Olímpicos de
Invierno en Beijing el próximo año
[Aplausos]